Let's start. I am Atsuku Matsumura president of the Diamond Dining Group
Let's begin
Skip this
At Diamond Dining Group we work in the restaurant business
Amusement business and overseas wedding business as a company listed on the first section of Tokyo Stock Exchange
It may not be obvious, but I am a president of a Tokyo Stock Exchange listed company
And
Our company has about 5000 employees, and over 277 stores
We have 192 stores along major stations on the Yamanote line
The 192 stores in Yamanote major stations
Is the most in restaurant companies
Then
For everyone here working in Roppongi Hills
I would like to introduce 13 stores that we have around the Roppongi and Azabujuban area
First, since I am from Koushi prefecture
This is the Kouchi's local dish Katsuo Warayaki
It is very delicious
Next is
Imaiya main branch in Roppongi, it is a Yakitori restaurant
This is also in front too
Then we have Bishokumaimon
This is by the entrance of Imoaraizaka
Then
This is because I was born in 1967
Myself, along with Kenichi Inamoto from Zetton
There is a designer named Yasumichi Morita who happens to also be the husband of Mao Daichi
This is a store created by the 3 of us, and we were all born in 1967, so we named it that
There is a lot of champagne in this place
When you get to your seat, there is a champagne cooler right in front of you
And champagne bottles sticks out from there
The champagne just opens up on its own
In a month, there was a time that we sold 800 bottles of Moet
It is a champagne filled store
Next is
Public Six
It is a new sports bar in front of 1967
And then we have
Carpet Tokyo
A lot of money had been spent on this one
It is on the 2nd floor where Public Six is, and a lot of money was spent on the carpets
It is definitely a classy restaurant
Yakitori Shinoda
This is a membership only store
It is the most expensive Yakitori restaurant in Japan
Please ask your boss to take you
Then
Also a membership only restaurant
Since I am from Tosa of Kouchi prefecture, we made the Tosa Cuisine Restaurant "Katsuhama"
Then we have
This place called Under
This is also a membership only bar
Then
There is a hotel in front of the station
Within the Roppongi Hills district
Here, we have a beer themed store Glass Dance
The Steak Roppongi, this is a steakhouse
We also have in our amusement section called Bagus
You can play billiards, darts, table tennis
There is also golf simulation, and various games and entertainment
You can easily get hooked when you go
In line with this
We also have a cyber café, or an internet café
It is a Manga café
This is also something we have
So
Let's get into today's topic
I'd like to present today's topic
I, Matsumura, read "Ten Things I Know to be True"
I was strongly moved, and thought about the affinity it had on my business
The title is
"Atsuku Matsumura's Ten Things I Know to be True"
Thank you for finding it funny
Focus on the user and all else will follow.
Always think form the perspective of the user
Our company philosophy when we were founded is to "provide joy to the customers"
It has something in common
How can we give an enjoyable experience to the user, or the customers that come in
Not from what is beneficial to the company, but what would bring joy to the customer
In our strategy for opening stores, first thing we consider is "what is needed in the location or the market"
From a line of business that we wanted to do, we created 100 stores of 100 different lines of businesses that the users wanted to have
Each store had a different type of business, and we were able to achieve opening 100 stores
And, as an effort to understand from the perspective of the user
We implemented DD miles, where the customer that made the reservation would benefit from
For example, if the host reserved for 10 people, then they would also receive miles for 10 people
And, we also have a call center
We also have user support within our headquarters when reservations cannot be made directly to the store
Let us go to the second one
It's best to do one thing really, really well.
It is best to strengthen things that you are good at
What can we do?
To be able to make it better, every since we were a small company
We had in-house advertising and designers
And, in the restaurant industry back then, it was very unique to have them in-house
We recruited specialists of different genres and for financial affairs, business planning, store development, and we trained them
As a result, our design team built a great reputation
And, our advertising team also built a great reputation, and we continued to have great impact on the industry
Then, we were not a design company but
We received the gold award for the "20th All Japan DM Awards"
This is usually rewarded to a design company
But, a restaurant business received this award, which created much controversy
We also strengthened our service
About 10 years ago our company had the reputation of
the store being colorful but nothing more, and having terrible service, and bad food quality
To resolve this
There is S1 Grand Prix, it is the Service Grand Prix
We currently join the S1 Grand Prix
And, we were able to receive the first prize
This year, the finals is on March 15th
There are 2 finals from Tokyo
And 1 finals in Osaka, and all three are monopolized by our company
We are pretty despized because of this
If you do too well, especially that Japanese has a culture of rooting for the underdog
If you are doing to well, it is not looked upon on very well
Fast is better than slow
Speed multiplied by success angle is what I think is growth
We have used the business line development and M&A strategy
It is quite difficult to create each one and separate businesses
We were creating these stores that all had separate concepts
It was very difficult
With M&A, we also use this to buy time
We usually remodel our stores
With M&A, we also take the strategy of buying time
This is how much we've used the M&A strategy, from small businesses to larger scaled businesses
In the restaurant industry, I believe there is the 30 billion Yen limit
The moment it goes close to 30 billion Yen, it stalls
For example
If I mention the name I might get in trouble
These companies growth has stalled the moment it reached 30 billion Yen
The reason behind this may vary, such as the charisma of the owner had been lost
Obsolescence of the brand
They had been blinded too much by successful strategies and experiences, that they were not able to deliver anything new anymore
They were not able to adapt to changes, and they lack innovation
There was an employee that said something like this
There are 3 things you will need to innovate
First thing is, the young ones, outsiders, and idiots, these are the 3 things you need
We can have young people by recruiting fresh graduates
We can have outsiders by recruiting experienced people
Then, for the idiot, we have you president, so we should be set
I told him to hold his tongue
When these 3 come together, that is when innovation can happen for the first time
And
M&A is an effective growth strategy
When we reached 30 billion Yen
We also fell in this hole
And, for about 5 years, we were struggling
Because of this, we used the strategy of speed times success angle
Refine regenerating skills, secure talented personnel, excellent location strategy
Frequent business decision equals to acquiring decision-making skills, and has the potential of a good chemistry
I think there is only growth to happen
Democracy on the web works.
In company growth, girl power is a must
At Diamond Dining, our ratio of female employees is as the following
Headquarters female managerial positions 42%
Overall female employees 43%
Fresh graduates female employees 55%
We have a lot of female employees
We also have GAGA WOMAN
This is the female version of our internal newsletter
That is my secretary
She is on the cover
Also, I am very strict to male employees
But, I never scold female employees
Can you guess why?
It is simple
It's this
"I don't want to be hated by women." It is as simple as that
I want to have a harmonious time at work
So, I try not to tell off female employees as much
You don't need to be at your desk to need an answer
Look into 100 stores, this is very important
If you want to make a Yakiniku restaurant, look into 100 existing Yakiniku restaurants, you will not fail
If you look into 100 stores, you can take the good parts, and not copy the bad parts
If you do this, you will not fail
Look into 100 stores, this is a good phrase
Creative starts from the eye
If you do not look at a wide range of things, you will not be able to build anything
The best way is to travel, and go to many different places
But of course we don't have the time or the money for it
In that case, when you go out to eat, you can look at different signages, go to different restaurants
Look into different logos, look at the menu of other companies
Or, you can watch a movie
Read a book, scan through magazines
Anyhow, it is important to expose your eyes to many things
See it with your own eyes, see a lot, and it is important to shower yourself with visuals
Restaurant names are also very important
I haven't had time these days to do this but
If I have time, I would go to the book store, or the DVD rental store
And look at the titles of rental movies, and I would try to remember the names in my head
Next is
You can make money without doing evil
The restaurant industry has a very low profit ratio
Healthy and safe ingredients must be used, and it has to be cheap
Customers also expect a high quality of service
There are also many complaints from the customer
Your subordinates would complain, and your customer would get angry at you, and your superior would scold you
It is a very hard industry to be in
All types of work are hard, but if I were to be born again, I would not work in the restaurant industry
This is something that I always say publicly
I would work for Google
Next is
There's always more information out there
Shower yourself with information
This is very true
Input, input, input
I said that creativity start from the eye
If you do take in a lot of information, you will be left behind
Because of the popularity of smartphones, I believe that work will reduce down to half
This is the Gran Cyber Café
It looks very cool
This is what a manga café looks like these days
It looks very good
If you do not work on gathering information, you will not be able to keep up
Gather information, and input, input, input
I think collecting various information is the only way
Because you have these drawers filled with information, when different things come your way
You will be able to deal with them, experience is really something that can't be turned to money
Really look into many things, the only way is to input in your head
Of course, creative starts form the eye
But you must read books to gain knowledge
It was on the news yesterday, or the day before
But lately, people have stopped reading books
More than half of the people do not read books anymore
What do they spend their time on instead? They use their smartphones
They don't read books
There was also a time that I loved books
But I haven't found the time to read as much anymore
There is a person at the company that loves reading books
His nickname is library
I would let him read a particular book, and just listen to the essence of it from him
Most of the time, this works
Don't you think this is a smart way to do it
I would give him the book, and ask him to give me the points
He loves reading books, so he takes it with pleasure
Then I would just ask him
The need for information crosses all borders
About our overseas strategy
Hawaii
We have started to penetrate the Hawaiian market
We want to be the number one restaurant business in Hawaii
There are not many restaurants in Hawaii
There are not many restaurant business there
The language is different from Japan, the culture is different, so it's very difficult
Licenses would not pass, and there also problems with the visa
It is very difficult
The president of our restaurants in Hawaii
He was chosen as the number one Japanese president in Hawaii 2 years in a row
Hide Sakurai
He looks Japanese, he is born Japanese, but inside, he is completely American
And
I've also mentioned him earlier, but my batch mate and same age Kenichi Inamoto from Zetton
The plan is for both of them to be in charge of expanding from Hawaii
to America mainland
Next we have
You can be serious without a suit
This boils down to our trust in employees
At our company
If you put it in a positive light, we implement a bold delegation of authority
If you put it in a less positive light, then we give all the responsibilities on the employees
To create independence and proactivity among employees
We ask our employees to keep these 3 promises, to keep customers happy, not to leave out the concept, and to secure appropriate profit
As long as they keep these rules, they can do almost anything that they want
They can create the menu that they like, they can play the music that they like
They can put the pricing that they like
They can set the working hours at any time
But, they will have to keep these 3 rules
As long as they keep these 3, then they can do anything
The employees have a lot of freedom
And
It may not seem like it, but I am also called the number one fashionista in the industry
So what, right?
Feel free to laugh
I was featured on a magazine called Forza style
Next
Oh, it's a separate mook
Next we have
Great just isn't good enough
Not being satisfied with the current is the motivating power
With humans, the moment that you feel satisfied, everything stops
I think that you must keep running
Always hold a high goal, and it is important to strive to be the leading company in the industry
This is true, the moment you become complacent
Everyone else will surpass you
You will only be waiting for the end
You have to keep running
Especially with restaurant businesses, even if you are running ahead, it doesn't mean that you will win
With IT, if you are ahead, then you will win
If you run way ahead of everyone, it is very hard to keep up
With the restaurant industry, it's like a game
It doesn't matter if it's a store that makes 100 billion, or a small store that only makes 10,000 Yen a day
It does not matter
That's why it's hard
It is very hard
And
I put importance in surprises more than anything
I think surprises is what motivates me to move
I love surprising customer and the audience
I am from Kochi prefecture
And there is a festival called the Yosakoi festival
We have a team there
Our company's female employees are in charge of managing this team
Let's take a look at the footage
We are Diamond Dining
We are declaring a rage!
Yosakoi, Yosakoi
Yosakoi
We join every year, and we've joined for 3 times so far, and this year will be our 4th
This year, we want to get the highest award
Then
We also host year-end parties for 150 restaurant business executives
Restaurant owners are very spoiled
So it's very hard to hold an event like this
And
We also host about 30 birthday parties a year
I'd like to remind again that I am a president of a listed company on the Tokyo Stock Exchange
And
Here is Hikari GENJI
I've also done Spiderman
Beethoven
I have never seen Beethoven, so I'm not very sure
This is the Beethoven within my fantasy
This is another Beethoven
Rassun Gorerai
I've actually done a lot
This is Star Wars at the year-end party
We didn't have much budget, I am the one in the gold
This C-3PO is terrible
And, there's also Piko Taro, I thought I had to do it right away
We looked for one all over Japan
Then we found one from the Tokyu Hands in Shinsaibashi Osaka
We reserved, and had it delivered from Osaka
Then
That is Piko Taro
At the menu grandprix
SEKAI NO OSAWARI, all are employees except for myself
The one in purple hair is myself, and the others are employees
Then
We dressed up as Kouji Kikawa and did a Complex
I was invited to a friend's birthday party
They told me to do a band, and I said I can only do an air band
So, we took part as an air band
It was a proper band house, and I think it gave the look of an actual band
It looks like this
And
Can you tell what this is?
Sunshine
There is an extremely good-looking actor named Saito-san, and I copied his character in the show Gakinotsukai
Then
I do calligraphy as well
When I tried it out, it turned out pretty well
Please take a look
That is Hatsudori, the first cockcrowing of the year, I wrote it in one take in the new years
I think it turned out good
Then
I would like to say this again, but I put importance in surprises more than anything
Being great is not good enough
Surprise is number one
Finally
I would like to share with everyone my favorite quote
My favorite quote is
Rockets are not made as an extension of an airplane
It was made from the desire of the passion to go to the moon
I'd like to ask
What is your moon?
I always think about this when I work
I , Matsumura, will always feel like a Google employee in the inside
Thank you for listening